today on the matt welsh show a new
report reveals how men have abandoned
the university system why has this
happened i think i know why and i'll
explain also satanists are coming to the
defense of the abortion the pro-abortion
people down in texas what does that tell
us about the pro-abortion movement and
our daily cancellation we will have
another exciting reverse cancellation
apparently some people are upset because
i said that females shouldn't be
football analysts and that for some
reason has made people unhappy we'll
talk about that and much more today
you know it's playing out right now at
big tech companies and social media
sites that's i think a really dangerous
precedent the fight back against big
tech's control of the internet i use
expressvpn you ever wondered how free to
access tech giants make all their money
while they do it by tracking your
searches your video history everything
you click on by building a profile on
you and then they sell your sensitive
data and that's how they make the money
when you use expressvpn
and you use the app on your computer on
your phone you make yourself anonymous
so that your online presence is hidden
and you're hiding your ip address and
that gives you the privacy you deserve
that means that it means that the big
tech companies can't make all this money
off of you without even giving you a cut
of it what's more expressvpn encrypts
100 of your network data to protect you
from eavesdroppers and cybercriminals
what i like most about is how easy it is
to use you just take one click click one
button and that's it so let's stop
allowing big tech to revoke our rights
to free speech
why not revoke their right to your data
instead secure your internet with the
vpn i trust for online protection visit
expressvpn.com walsh that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh to get three extra months free
with my exclusive link go to
expressvpn.comwalsh
right now to learn more
all right we are broadcasting live from
uh some random warehouse on the side of
a highway you know look there are many
mysteries in life one of them being why
are we here
uh questions that evade answer phenomena
that defy explanation unidentified
flying objects for example though we
have an explanation for that we know
that they're aliens but you get the
point
there are many things which happen and
yet have no satisfactory reason
uh for them that we can come up with
here is one thing though that
there is no mystery behind at all
there's no mystery to this
uh this report from the wall street
journal which has been making the rounds
has attracted a lot of attention over
the past couple of days and the headline
is a generation of american men give up
on college the number of men enrolled at
two and four-year colleges has fallen
behind uh women by record levels in a
widening education gap across the u.s
now this can very easily be explained i
think but before we explain it
here's what the article says
men are abandoning higher education in
such numbers that they now trail female
college students by record
levels at the close of the 2020-2021
academic year women made up 59.5 of
college students an all-time high and
men 40 percent according to enrollment
data from the national student
clearinghouse a non-profit research
group u.s colleges universities had 1.5
million fewer students compared with
five years ago and men accounted for 71
of the decline which is astounding this
education gap which holds at both two
and four-year colleges has been slowly
widening for 40 years the divergence
increases at graduation after six years
of college
65 of women in the us who started a
four-year university in 2012 received
diplomas by 2018 compared with 59 of men
during the same period according to the
u.s department of education
in the next few years
uh two women will will earn a college
degree for every man if the trend
continues
okay then article goes on to explain
that this trend holds among both rich
and poor men black and white it's not
confined by you know class or race
men are abandoning the college system or
being abandoned by the system i should
say or both
and it's an issue that affects men of
all types now the piece also
acknowledges
how the university system is reluctant
to see this problem as a problem and is
certainly not anxious to actually do
anything to increase male enrollment
because that would be politically
incorrect
even the people who want to increase
male enrollment
still aren't fighting for that result
for the sake of the men themselves
so a college enrollment consultant named
jennifer delahunty
uh is interviewed in in the article
and she's of the opinion that we should
actually do something to help these guys
out get more guys into colleges but
here's the reason she gives she says
if you care about our society one and
two if you care about women
you have to care about the boys too
if you've equally educated numbers of
men and women that just makes a better
society and it makes it better for women
so uh yeah so
we must come to the aid of men
for the sake of women
and this is what someone who basically
cares about men in comparison to other
people in the university system says
now consider that most of the people
running university system don't care at
all and don't pretend to
or in fact worse than that are happy to
see things shake out this way
as for why this is all happening
nobody interviewed by the wall street
journal seems to have any idea
they're all kind of scratching their
heads and saying i don't know why aren't
men coming here
let me see if i can clear it up a little
bit
to put it as simply as possible
men are declining to go to college
because they don't want to pay thousands
of dollars and go into debt for 25 years
just to hear a bunch of crusty boomer
professors and ugly pink-haired wenches
tell them that they're the cause of all
of society's ills okay that's that's to
put it gently that's the reason
and then only to be accused of course of
rape for kissing a girl at a party and
then tried by a university kangaroo
court branded a sex offender for the
rest of their lives without any
evidence i think this is an invitation
that lots of men
are kind of reluctant to accept
and maybe you can understand why
i mean just just as another example if i
need another example and there are like
millions we could choose but let's just
play one this is a clip from a recent
class at penn state
and you watch this
and you tell me if it's any wonder that
people aren't too excited about paying a
hundred grand for this listen how's it
feel knowing that push comes to shove
like your skin's kind of nice
i don't know i mean it makes me feel
like
sad because like god knows i don't
deserve it you know what i mean like i
didn't choose to be white so like
you know what i mean like it makes me
upset that like
you know
my brothers and sisters of like other
races can't like experience those things
for something that i didn't like
you know i didn't do anything to like
deserve that you know what i mean so
like just makes me upset
so so we're in
this is the problem with white people
the question then becomes is what should
we do
so
what's what's not to love there um of
course that was that was
race and gender-based not just gender
but
pulling a guy up in front of the class
aren't you ashamed of yourself
confess your sins to the class
what a shock that men see that and think
you know i don't know i don't know if i
want to be a part of that
not to mention men are increasingly
noticing that a college education is
rarely worth the cost and they can find
success in the job market without the
enduring you know without enduring the
financial and psychological toll of
sitting through four years of far-left
brainwashing
furthermore even if some of these men
could be convinced to go in spite of all
this
there really isn't anyone trying to
convince them
now girls have a whole web of support
systems in place especially in school
and public school
in grade school to prop them up
encourage them keep them going which is
good
what's not good is that men have none of
that at all i mean they're not allowed
to have anything
and as i discovered you know if you if
you notice that men don't have their own
spaces then and you point that out and
you complain about that then that that
in itself is sexism
in fact the entire public school system
itself is itself
a support system for girls the public
school system was made for girls it
caters exclusively to students who can
sit still learn calmly at their desks
memorize information
remember that information and repeat it
during an exam now not all girls can
learn this way there are certainly girls
who struggle as well but it is surely
the case the vast majority of kids who
can learn that way
are girls
for the boys what do we have we have
drugs and if the drugs don't help
they're out of luck
i mean do we do we still need more
reasons why men aren't going to college
because i can keep listening
remember though
this is what male privilege looks like
of course
the education system caters to girls
they succeed in it they go to college
boys are far more likely to be drugged
in school
i think like two by two to one margin i
believe or maybe more than that they get
diagnosed with adhd and put on drugs
more likely to be suspended more likely
to be expelled
more likely to be abandoned by the
system and then they enter a world as
adults where they're far more likely to
end up homeless drug-addicted murdered
imprisoned
more likely to be injured on the job
more likely to die by their own hand or
someone else's and they die earlier on
average
that's some privilege all right isn't it
now i say all this
but uh please don't
misunderstand my point
i am not upset
by the trend of young men skipping
college
i'm upset by many of these other trends
that i just talked about
but but not by that
in fact this is one of the most
encouraging things that i've read in a
while
the modern university system is a scam
it's a glorified ponzi scheme
it has built entire generations robbed
them of their financial future not to
mention their minds and their souls and
it's made them dumber in return
it would be impossible to exaggerate the
the disaster that the system has become
it is an intellectual and moral
wasteland
and it's been skating by on unearned
prestige for decades it has made
billions by taking advantage of kids who
have been told and believe
that college is the only path to success
in life
it's made billions by scaring people
into into believing that they have no
choice we know it's expensive we know
you're going to be in debt for for 30
years uh yeah we can't guarantee that
you get a job out of college that you
couldn't have gotten
anyway without the college degree but if
you don't do this then you're then look
at all those people on the street you
can end up like one of them
that has been the scam
if men are waking up to this fact then
all i can say is that half of the job is
done now it's all just time for women
more women to realize the same truth
college in most cases is worse than
useless
the more who realize this truth and free
themselves from its clutches
i would say the better
now let's get to our five headlines
you know if you're pro-life you
shouldn't have to justify the right to
life in daily conversation abortion is
what needs constant justification not
life 40 days for life has just released
the perfect book though because the
reality is that actually you do have to
have your defenses and know what you're
going to say as a pro-life person even
though it seems like this is such a
self-evident point of view and it is
that's what their book's all about
though it's called what to say when the
complete new guy discussing abortion
this book is an easy read for
individuals looking to defend life and
convert hearts a lot has changed
obviously since abortion was legalized
in 1973 what to say when equips readers
with proven approaches to dismantling
the pro-abortion agenda these methods
have already enabled 40 days for life
members to convert the hearts of 221
abortion workers so you know it works
you got to know exactly what to say and
not say when abortion comes up this is
an invaluable tool and it's officially
available right now so you don't want to
wait to get your copy i can tell you
that uh i wrote the full word for it so
you know i can personally endorse it as
well but it's it's and i've also read
the book as a pro-life person myself i
found that there's quite a lot that's
valuable within it so what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion is available you can get free
shipping and 21 off a signed hardback at
40daysforlife.com
what to say when
okay so here's a story from salon that
i've had here for a couple days and uh i
i certainly needed to mention
it says
uh as we go back to the abortion law
down in texas
it says as pro-choice and reproductive
health groups are scrambling to make
sense of texas's new near-total abortion
ban that went into effect this week it
appears their efforts to skirt the law
are getting an unexpected boost from one
organization in particular the satanic
temple
the supreme court uh on wednesday night
allowed the state to implement its ban
so on and so forth we know about that
enter the satanic temple the
non-theistic organization which is
headquartered in salem massachusetts
non-theistic in quotes there that's what
they call themselves they joined the
legal fray this week by sending a letter
to the u.s food and drug administration
demanding access to abortion pills for
its members the group has established an
abortion ritual
and is attempting to use the religious
freedom restoration act to argue that
its members should be allowed access to
abortion drugs for religious purposes
the satanic temple spokesperson lucian
greaves told the san antonio current
i am sure texas attorney general ken
paxton who famously spends a good deal
of his time composing press releases
about religious liberty issues in other
states will be proud to see that texas's
robust religious liberty laws which he
so vociferously champions will prevent
future abortion rituals from being
interrupted by superfluous government
restrictions meant only to shame and
harass those seeking an abortion now
you could say that this is uh that
there's a lot of trolling going on by
the satanic temple and that's
that it seems like that's how they spend
most of their time kind of like peta
that's they're they're there's in fact
there are a lot of comparisons you can
make between peta and the satanic temple
we won't get into all of them right here
but that's a show unto itself but
probably the primary thing is they spent
a lot of time trolling so you could say
that that's what this is
i don't expect that this legal challenge
will really go anywhere
but
there's a real deep truth here and and
i'm i'm actually glad that
they're making this attempt
assuming that it's not gonna work
because it's true
that abortion is in in essence a satanic
ritual
the only
misleading thing here is the idea that
you have to be officially you know a
member of the satanic temple to take
part in this religious ritual or or to
see it as such
um
what is a satanist
okay
satanist follows their leader
satan
uh
in rejecting god
and saying i am going to worship myself
i don't want god i want myself so
satanism
it doesn't have to be
you know there is
there's the kind of theistic satanism
where we're literally worshiping the
devil
there's probably not a whole lot of that
happening not directly
and and the people who belong to the
satanic temple they'll tell you that no
we don't we don't we don't sacrifice
goats on the altar
spill the blood and you know honor of
our sa of of lucifer
they'll be pretty direct and tell you no
this is just about celebrating us it's
about celebrating our you know our our
freedom
and that's what satanism is
so there are a lot of satanists in this
country who don't identify as
the people who believe in worshiping the
self that's what leftism is i i've
always said that i think leftism and
satanism are interchangeable they're the
same thing they are both a worship an
elevation of the self above all else
above truth above god above beauty you
know all that mat above reality itself
all that matters is the self
abortion is
the high sacrament
of
this satanic leftism
what what other what higher sacrament
could there be then a woman killing her
own child for her sake
saying that i care so much about my
convenience
and my pleasure
and my so-called freedom that i will
kill my own child i will sacrifice my
child on this altar the altar of the
self
so they are it's a long way of saying
that i actually agree with them
that that abortion is in effect in a
religious ritual
but it should still be banned because
you're murdering a human being
uh staying on the same subject here look
i don't mean to to kick a woman while
he's down but here's caitlyn jenner's
answer on abortion being uh he's being
interviewed on on cnn
and we'll talk about why caitlyn jenner
polling at one percent is being
interviewed by cnn in the first place
but here's the answer on abortion let's
listen to this
i am for a women's right to choose
i am also for
a state
uh having the ability to make their own
laws
um and so i support
texas in that decision that's their
decision
um i'm okay with that
but as far as being a woman's right to
choose i don't see any changes in our
laws in california in the future but
you're fine with the texas law even
though you say
that you support abortion rights you're
fine with the law that essentially
outlaws abortion
i think they have the right in their
state to do what they want to do now do
i agree with the decision or not
no to be honest with you i actually
probably do not agree with the decision
but i agree with they have the right to
make their own decision
really the
the perfect republican i mean he really
is
a terrible candidate but the perfect
republican because that's that's what
republicans have been doing uh many
republicans anyway thank god not the
republicans down in texas that's what
many republicans have been doing on the
issue of abortion
especially republicans on the national
stage for decades now
well do i you know do i i think people
have states have rights but then women
have rights and who knows i you know i
don't personally like abortion but
i'm not in favor of killing infants
uh you know i'm i'm not crazy when i i'm
not crazy about the idea of crushing a
baby skull personally i'm not into it
but if that's your thing and i'm not
going to stop like that's the kind
that's what we get from republicans
that's what we get from
from gender there
which is which is cowardly and
ridiculous
but it's what it's what we've come to
expect the other question though is why
is jenner being interviewed by cnn in
the first place and the funny thing is
that
you know a lot of people on the left
who
maybe
maybe and i hate to say this but aren't
quite as smart as the people at cnn not
that the people at cnn are very smart
but they were upset about this
if you looked at the reaction on twitter
they were saying why are you giving a
platform to caitlyn jenner
you know you might have the same
question if you're a conservative you
might say pulling it one percent in the
re this this person is irrelevant why
why are you interviewing them why not
larry elder
um
well the answer is that this is the
version
of the republican party this kind of
babbling nonsensical
uh spineless
gelatinous
jellyfish like
republicanism that's what they want
to project that's what that's what cnn
that's what cnn wants to give a platform
too
cnn wants you to turn on and turn that
on and listen to caitlyn jenner babbling
and say oh that's what the republicans
are all about so that's the reason
more republican reaction now to the
abortion law governor abbott was during
press conference was asked about
the the the question about what about
rape victims are we going to force women
to carry their rapist baby
and uh here's what he said to that
what's this
regarding the heartbeat film why force a
rape or incest victim to carry a
pregnancy between
uh it doesn't require that at all
because obviously it provides at least
six weeks
for a person uh to be able to
get an abortion so for one it doesn't
provide that that said however let's
make something very clear
rape
is a crime
and texas will work tirelessly to make
sure that we eliminate all rapists from
the streets of texas by aggressively
going out and
arresting them and prosecuting them and
getting them off the streets
uh
i don't mean to split hairs here but not
a great answer
on that question
and it's it's not really splitting hairs
because this is a question that you yeah
you need to have an answer to
it's of course absurd that the
conversation about abortion revolves
always around rape and that when we talk
about abortion rape is the rape and
incest so the first things that come up
because we're talking about less than
one percent of all cases okay the vast
majority of cases
more than 99 of cases have nothing to do
with rape nothing to do with incest
99 nothing to do with the life of the
mother okay so all those categories
that's one percent altogether less than
one percent rape life of the mother uh
you know incest
and really life of the mother actually
is a fictional category because it's
never in reality necessary to have an
abortion to save a mother's life she may
have to deliver a child early that does
happen there's no reason why you have to
kill the child on the way out of the
womb
um so but all together we're talking
about one percent
and yet that's all the pro-abortion side
wants to talk about they don't want to
talk about the 99
for obvious reason
it's a lot harder to defend that
the 99 of cases where this is a form of
after the fact birth control they don't
want to talk about that let's talk about
the rape
um
so you do have to have an answer for it
you have to have some kind of response
and you give your response and then you
and then you focus it back to the 99
greg abbott there goes with well it's a
crime we're getting the rapist off the
street
you know that's not terribly persuasive
because the reality of especially that
particular crime is that you're never
going to get all the rapists off the
street
the the most you can hope for is that
after a rape has happened
then you convict the person
and throw them in jail
and a lot of times they still end up
back on the street at some point
but they should be in jail really they
should just be executed we should be
done with it
but
before the crime happens it's it's very
very difficult to prevent
so you have to deal with that reality
that yes tragically
horribly this this will happen
what's the answer then to the what about
rape question
to me the answer is simple
we do not punish children
for the crimes of their parents
okay we're not going to execute a child
because his father was a rapist
and then you might further say to the
pro-abortion side if you guys
want to execute somebody for rape we can
talk about that
i'm not putting that all off the table
but it's going to be the crump the
criminal the rapist who gets that
penalty
now let's go back and talk about the 99
all right finally on this subject one
more clip i got to play this is uh
alexandria casey cortez on cnn
babbling incoherently uh let's listen
so when we talk about um
the law that was passed in texas
we know that anti-choice bills
are not about being pro-life because if
they were about being pro-life
then the republican party would support
frankly an agenda that helps
guaranteed health care that helps ensure
that people who do give birth that don't
have the resources to care for a child
can have that care for a child so we
know that none of this is about life
none of this is about supporting life
what this is about is controlling
women's bodies and controlling people
who are not cisgender men this is about
making sure that someone like me as a
woman or any menstruating person in this
country cannot make decisions over their
own body and people like governor abbott
and mitch mcconnell want to have more
control over over a woman's body than
that woman or that person has over
themselves and what what that shares in
uh in
you know what that shares with rape
culture is that sexual assault is about
the abuse of power and sexual assault is
about asserting control over another
person and the ease
with which these men seek to do that to
other people
is atrocious it is morally reprehensible
and they don't they cannot even begin to
understand the agonizing decisions that
people have to make including in cases
of miscarriage
rape and incest
it's hard to know where to even begin
why we talk about miscarriage that has
nothing to do with abortion whatsoever
nothing to do with it
and she says agonizing decisions why is
an agonizing decision alexandria tell me
why it's agonizing what do you mean why
is it agonizing
if if this is not a person but a clump
of cells if they're if their life means
nothing has no moral worth which is what
you must believe if you're pro-abortion
then why is it agonizing what are we
agonizing about
what are you agonizing about well you're
agonizing it's an agonizing decision
because that's a human being that's
being killed but of course alexandria
case of cortez like all democrats they
can't even talk about this issue anymore
because they have uh they've erased
gender they've erased sex so how you you
you certainly can't frame this
as an attack on women because that's
nonsensical to begin with but also
because well women aren't the only ones
who could get pregnant and you could see
how they you know they they still
haven't figured out how to navigate that
because it's impossible to navigate
because it's it's incoherent
so you see how she begins by saying well
this is an attack on pregnant women and
then and then she transitions and she
says oh and all menstruating people so
is it an attack on women or not but then
she goes back and saying this they want
to control women's bodies but i thought
you said it's this this this it's not
just women why why are you why are you
talking about women you seem to be
suggesting
that only women get pregnant which isn't
uh
and meanwhile this this idea of we're
controlling women's bodies that makes no
sense for a variety of reasons of course
we're not talking about the woman's body
we're talking about the child's body but
also you see how these people they talk
about erasing women they erase women in
general but
they they simply pretend that pro-life
women don't exist
that this is all a plot by men
who misogynistic men who want to control
women meanwhile as someone who's been in
the pro-life movement for years
you go to the marches you go to the you
know the the vigils outside of abortion
clinics you go to the fundraising
banquets any anywhere you go you go to a
you know a pregnancy resource center any
of these places
is mostly women not just there but
they're the ones running the show the
pro-life movement is a movement run and
led and mostly populated by women that's
the reality okay
uh one other quick thing i want to play
the media is now in full-on fear-monger
mode over college football fans
attending games
and they sound
they just sound extremely stupid in the
process i got to play this clip for you
a guy worrying this is a doctor who came
on cnn
to chastise the football fans especially
he's concerned that the football fans
are i believe he says
exhaling vigorously in the stands listen
i just can't get over the pictures of
those outdoor stadiums dr schaffner even
if you know these events are happening
outdoors
are crowds like that safe
oh anna we wouldn't ever talk about
being safe i don't use that four-letter
word but they these crowds do provide a
risk this delta variant is so readily
spread that even outdoors where people
are cheering and enthusiastic
exhaling with vigor if there are people
infected they can infect people around
them
i looked at those television images
nobody was wearing a mask at all
and i would be
very surprised if we didn't have
outbreaks here and there across the
country related to these uh gatherings
these uh football stadium events uh in
in the coming weeks
exhaling with vigor
look at all these people breathing with
abandon out here this is this is
reckless behavior who are you to go
outside and breathe
we want them to stan to sit in the
stands and just hold their breath the
entire time why can't they do that the
doctor is wondering
but as part of this fear-monger mode um
you know there was actually good news
that we got from from the cdc
uh but it's important to realize how the
media and the powers that be
can lie
while telling the truth technically so
here's a great example this is a u.s
news
this is their the headline in the first
paragraph
from the cdc
cdc studies document higher cova 19
hospitalization rates in children during
delta surge it goes on to say increased
transmission of the delta chronovirus
variant has coincided with higher
hospitalization rates among those under
the age of 18 according to a pair of
studies published by the cdc from late
june to mid august weekly cove 19
associated hospitalization rates among
children adolescents increased nearly
five-fold okay that's the scary part you
put that in the headline
this echoes what the cdc itself said uh
they tweeted this they said from late
june to mid-august there was a ten times
increase in the rate of hospitalizations
among children ages zero to four
sounds very scary
but now let's go let's go back to that
u.s news article
a little bit further down this is what
they say
however the proportions of hospitalized
children and adolescents with severe
disease were similar before and during
the period of delta predominance the
study said indicating that the highly
transmissible variant does not seem to
cause more severe disease in children
than previous strains so why are you
saying that the hospitalization rates
have gone up
now what we discover is that well the
hospitalization rate is actually
extremely low thank god
but more kids are getting the virus so
the overall number
in the hospital which is still very low
comparatively speaking has naturally
gone up
so the actual headline now you you could
set even though that's the case
that the actual number has gone up but
the but the the the illness is not any
more severe than it was before for kids
you could still technically say that the
hospitalization rate has gone up
but the media knows and the cdc knows
they know that when people read that
they know how it'll be interpreted
that you think that the rate of people
of kids getting sicker getting more you
know getting more severe illnesses has
gone up so it's all it's just a it's
just kind of a
way of confusing you
the the real headline
they don't just bury the lead here
they try to make it seem like the lead
is the exact opposite of what it really
is the real headline is that after all
of this fear-mongering over the delta
variant
and how we got to have kids masking in
school we got to rush this vaccine into
their arms
it's it's it's it's the same as it was
before
which is that it poses almost no severe
risk to children at all okay moving now
to read the youtube comments
this is from uh
henry i said he says i think the idea of
white guilt reparations and being
responsible for what your ancestors did
is unjust and evil
likewise i think the idea of original
sin is unjust as well i would love to
hear your thoughts well henry i think
you're correct to link the white guilt
thing to a religious idea because it is
itself a religious idea so i agree with
you there
the difference though
well there are two differences
one is that
the doctrine of original sin
is a religious doctrine
and those of us who believe in it like
myself
we don't hide from that fact
we're not claiming that it's anything
other than that it doesn't mean it's not
true we believe that it's true of course
but it's a it's a religious doctrine
it's part of our faith
uh so much of what you get from the left
white guilt you know this guilt passed
down through the blood of your ancestors
they don't admit what that is if they
were to come out and say listen this is
our religion this is part of what we
believe
i would still say that it's hideous and
wrong but at least you're being honest
so that's the first thing the other
thing is that original sin is all about
humanity's fallen nature
as a whole it doesn't single out any
particular race
and it also observes something that we
all see around us i think it was c.s
lewis or jk chester and one of the two
who said that uh of all of the christian
doctrines he finds original sin to be
the least
challenging because it's it's you see it
all around you it's very clear that we
have a fallen human nature and that's um
and so that's that's the difference
uh
joe says matt walsh quoting nietzsche
i'm impressed i really like him because
he actually admits that without god
there is no purpose many atheists today
attempt and fail to find purpose
yeah my ability to quote nietzsche
really doesn't go beyond what i did in
the show opening i mean i know i know
the basic level of what he what he
believed but um there was a certain
honesty i think
not just with nietzsche but with with
atheists of that period
in that culture there was a
certain honesty about what it meant
if there is no god then that means that
there is no purpose
to life
and uh and so now there's a real problem
here of like why are we existing at all
what's the point
and i think a lot of atheists today as
you point out joe they
they want to gloss right over that they
don't want to talk about that they don't
even want it they don't want to admit
it's a problem
but it's a major one
um
let's see drummer zay94 says matt if you
dare ban me from the show i will reveal
the secrets of sbg and the origin of its
name the sweet baby gang has no origin
it has always existed
it will always exist
as i start to develop the uh the
mythology behind this this burgeoning
cult that we're starting and we are
starting a cult
it's important to to realize that we
don't talk about the order like many
cults scientology go to scientologist
building they're not going to tell you
where all this comes from right
it's going to be the same thing with
with spg well there's no better way to
wake up than with your once daily dose
of the facts that's why the daily wire
created morning wire the daily morning
show dedicated to bringing you all the
new news you need to know without any
spin or hidden agenda it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we're working
overtime to make sure fact based news
still has a platform
we need your help to keep it trending
and get it all the way to number one so
subscribe now to the morning wire and
leave it a five star review if you like
what you hear in honor of crowning the
winner of the sweet baby gang anthem
contest on monday i've got some extra
exciting news the request in a long
awaited sweet baby gang shirt is now
available at the link in the description
below i'm just learning this right now
this is exciting news
this is actually exciting not like when
i pretend to be excited by the ads um we
finally have the sweet baby gang shirt
there was a petition for it is now
available for you hurry because it's a
work of art and it will sell out again
the link to get your shirt is in the
description below thank you to all my
sweet babies for being here i hope you
will wear your sweet baby gang shirt
with pride let's move now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we have
another legendary iconic reverse
cancellation now if you listen to this
segment yesterday you probably already
know where this is heading we discussed
the female sports reporter lindsey go
who's suffering ptsd after being
violated and groped during a live report
from a college football game uh she
decided to do her to do her live hit
while 90 000 drunk fans were you know
walking by and a few of them screamed in
the background one briefly touched her
shoulder and this was all very traumatic
event for her
i suggested that perhaps sports
reporting isn't the job for her given
that she seems to really hate doing it i
probably could have just said that and
left it there and nobody would have been
all that upset about it but as you know
anytime i walk up against the fence like
that i have no choice but to just crash
right through it so i also said
that i don't really like female sports
reporters and analysts in football i
believe there's been an effort to
feminize
traditionally masculine spaces like
football and female analysts are part of
that
i prefer for men to have those roles
that was my stated opinion as it turns
out some people found it very upsetting
after the show was over media matters
sprang into action as expected they
posted the clip
they wrote up the article with the
headline daily wire host female sports
reporters are an effort to make the game
less appealing to the people the game
was invented for though i did prefer
jason over at media matters who uh he he
when posting the clip on on his personal
page he instead referred to me not as
daily wire host
but daily wire sexist which you know
i'll update my resume with with that new
title the female sports reporters of the
nation rushed to the scene to try and
get their dunks in they you know they
all let me know that my vicious misogyny
will not prevent them from continuing to
courageously report on sports and so on
and a bunch of men many of them also in
sports media joined in the dog pile
declaring that you know they for one
really respect and admire all the female
reporters unlike that matt walsh guy
they're one of the good guys so please
give them a pat on the head and give
them a treat they're saying
now i'm not going to restate my original
point or you know continue to argue
in favor of it i stand by it i don't
feel the need to explain myself again
i said what i wanted to say on the
subject and you could go back and listen
to it again if you want to experience it
all over again instead i'd like to make
a slightly different point here
even if you disagree with my opinion on
the subject
and you're free to disagree it's
nonetheless an opinion that lots of
football fans hold even if a great many
football fans uh you know
not just during this
even if they won't say it out loud the
fact is a great many people feel this
way
um and i i know that because i've heard
from them not just during this
discussion over the past day
but in general as a fan of the sport
having conversations with other fans
throughout my life whenever this subject
has come up
uh of you know they put the token female
down on the sideline isn't that kind of
silly that sort of thing i have found
that almost everyone i've ever talked to
feels this way to some extent
uh that they're not big fans of the
token female
uh they don't really want females in the
booth as analysts play by play-by-play
and so on
i've never been around any group
of fans in real life
where if i said exactly what i said on
the show
they would have stared back at me
wide-eyed and said what how dare you
this is i can't believe it this is
ludicrous that's outrageous how could
you say such a thing
i have never in my life ever gotten any
reaction like that or seen anyone else
get that reaction for saying what i said
or something similar yet that's the
reaction i got on the internet and from
media matters and from the media
now the fact that lots of people feel
this way and that it's pretty normal
pretty mainstream opinion in the real
world that doesn't make it right that's
not my point my point is that this is
yet another time one example of many
where a normal commonplace opinion or
preference is treated as if it's not
only wrong but shocking
now yeah it's it's a relatively small
issue
you know i do think it's symptomatic of
something larger which is the erasure of
male spaces and there's also a ratio of
female spaces happening at the same time
but the issue of female sports reporters
in and of itself not a big deal
i didn't say it was a big deal
i just said my opinion
but the game as always is to treat an
opinion a common opinion
even on a small issue especially on a
small issue in fact as if expressing it
is tantamount to mass murder right
so react this way to it
and lots of normal people with with that
normal opinion will kind of throw their
hands up and say whoa okay if it's that
big of a deal then never mind
this tactic i think is especially
effective on the small issues because
most people will figure that it's just
not worth fighting about okay if you
want me to like female sports reporters
fine i'll pretend that i do at least
just just to make you shut up and that's
how we normal people usually respond and
it's how we over time have been shaped
and molded by the media and the mob
agreeing to stay silent about this issue
over here agreeing to pretend to have
that opinion over there agreeing to you
know pretend that we're offended by this
or that and on and on little by little
playing the game in these seemingly
insignificant ways and not realizing
that all we ever do anymore is just play
the game and we've lost our authentic
selves
we don't even know what we think anymore
what our real opinions are
because we've been hectored into
submission piece by piece like getting
pecked to death by a million chirping
little parakeets
so why did i say what i said about
sports reporters well you know why do i
say many of the things i say on the show
well because i believe them to be true
first of all
i think it's a point worth making
but also i say say it because i know
you're not supposed to right
and i'm at the point now where if there
if there's like a weird code of silence
about something about anything
where we all believe something and feel
a certain way or have a certain opinion
but have agreed not to say it out loud
or in public
for fear of of the pecking parakeets
then i will say it just for that reason
you know you might call it trolling you
might call it contrainism you might call
it provocation for its own sake and you
might be right but the alternative
is just intolerable to me the
alternative is to
just shut up
and pretend that your opinions are not
your opinions
and so that is why i am not canceled
today and instead have once again
canceled my cancellers which is always a
fun thing to do
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
the new york times admits that life
begins at conception dr fauci gets
caught in a major lie and the taliban
disrespect george floyd check it out on
the michael knowles show